♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
I think it's important
to move...
a little bit, every day.
Stretch.
Yeah!
What?
Welcome to Painting with John
season two.
The show where I do not
teach you how to paint.
When season one
of the show came on,
I got so many people saying,
"Oh, you live in paradise,
you are so lucky."
And I'm just thinking,
"It is paradise.
But we didn't show you
the bad stuff."
Our washing machine...
During the rainy season,
there's these
little gnat things.
They don't sting you like a bee
'cause you rattled its nest,
they just sting you
'cause they're mean.
(GNAT BUZZING)
The horror.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
How do you like my boots?
I haven't been sleeping,
so I have
these dark circles
under my eyes.
And I imagine that somebody
would be flicking
through the channels and go,
"Honey,
there's a talking raccoon
on this channel.
And he's painting."
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
I have to be
completely candid,
I have these conversations
in my head when I'm painting.
We shot the first season,
and all these reviews are,
"I'd like to hang out
with John Lurie sometime.
He seems like a good person
to have a beer with."
But nobody who knows me
wants to hang out with me.
Life can be pretty horrible.
But there are also
beautiful moments.
I believe that human beings
should shine.
Shine from within.
There's no ending to this story,
so...
Thank you!